Hallo Chat, ich muss mein Headset entwirren, wobei, es hat sich teilweise selbst entwirrt.
Ey, wenn mal einer sowas erfindet, der könnte richtig reich damit werden.
Selbstentknotende Headsetkabel, oder generell selbstentknotende Kabel, das wär mal was,
das müsste man echt erfinden.
Chat, ich hab aufgerüstet, guck mal, was ich mir gekauft hab, nennt sich kabellos.
Ja, aber beim Headset mag ich das nicht, ich hab nen sturlosen Kopfhörer, ja das ist
ok, so noisecanceling Ding, aber hier gerade beim Headset, da schwör ich auf mein MMX
300 und ja, das könnte ich theoretisch an so ein Funkding machen, hab ich auch da, aber
dann brauch ich Batterien und so, naja, es sackt, alter.
Also, was wollt ich jetzt grad sagen, siehste, Chat, ich hab aufgerüstet, und zwar, ich
hab mir ein paar Sachen gekauft für Bastel Streams, und zwar einmal ein Elgato Ring Light
für n Tisch, dann hab ich mir ein Kameraarm für n Tisch gekauft, oder Stativtisch irgendwas
gekauft.
So was hier in der Richtung, nicht das, aber sowas in der Richtung, hab ich mir gekauft,
dann bin ich gerade dabei, falls hier sowas nicht dabei ist, da bin ich gerade dabei zu
gucken, was ich mir für das Telefon drucken kann, als Halter, und dann wird's hier richtig
Professional Bastel Stream, alter, aber gerade das Licht, da verspreche ich mir wirklich
ein bisschen was von, ja, Chat, das hier, viel zu teuer für den Shit, ne, da verspreche
ich mir allerdings tatsächlich ein bisschen was von, ich mein, das mach ich natürlich
nicht, aber 2500 Lumen ist ganz schön hell, aber es ist auf jeden Fall nice, dass man
schön was sieht auf dem Tisch, ja, da kann ich dann auch, da kann ich endlich mit Fabian
zusammen Schminktipps machen, da warten ja, warten ja die Welten auch immer drauf.
Chat, habt ihr alle mal ein Video geguckt von vorhin, wobei, die, die dabei waren, die
müssen das Video nicht gucken, weil die waren gestern im Stream dabei, Musik ist zu laut.
Guck mal, ich hab vorhin ein Video hochgeflangt, super Geschenke, 20 Weihnachtsgeschenke,
die jeder Informatikor, Techniker, Gamer braucht.
Das haben wir aber gestern, bisschen leise, das Video, wenn ich es ein bisschen lauter
machen muss, naja, man kann nicht alles haben, soll mal ein bisschen drehen am Knopf, tja,
gibt's denn da eigentlich?
Oh Video von Max, excellent, genau so ist richtig, ja, die Kratzer, das hat schon jeder mal erkannt.
Was ist denn ein Backforce, ist das eben ein Gaming Stuhl oder was, Gaming Stuhl ist Sacken.
Wegen der Amazon Promo Dislike, ok, ich hab aufgegeben die Logik der Leute zu verstehen,
da steht auf deinem Klingelschild ein Etikett, FPS steht da drauf, genau, na gut, also wir
halten uns ein bisschen ran und zwar was wir heute, 69 Zuschauer haben wir gerade, gatschi,
hyper.
So, ähm, wollen wir mal eine VM anmachen, wir machen doch endlich diesen komischen Javascript
Wizard fertig, dass das, ah das ist noch, ha, lustig, das ist noch wo ich heute aufgenommen
hab in der VM, ich hab das Sebaro, hat man das Subdomain angelegt, ja, Massive, wir machen
den Zauberer fertig, ja, wir zaubern den Magier fertig, also erstmal den ganzen Kram hier
zumachen, wow, nein, nein, nein, ich will es nicht ausmachen, ok, ich muss erstmal die
ganzen Sachen von der Aufnahme heute zumachen, ok, ok, ok, schon besser, schon besser, was
ist da oben, seht ihr das auch, warum ist Shadowplay auf einmal jetzt hier drin, was
macht Shadowplay da oben, könnt ihr mir das erklären, seit wann ist Shadowplay da oben
am Start, Low FPS Desktop, ja, warum ist, wartet mal, ich muss noch kurz das Kabel um
den Hals hängen, sonst macht es herzeitig dumme Geräusche, äh, so, ähm, warum ist
da jetzt auf einmal ein Shadowplay Ding oben, ich mein ich kann es ausmachen oder so, ok,
das ist aus, what, das ist ja sonst nie da oben, warum ist da ein Shadowplay Ding, ok,
wo kommt man den Kram ausschalten, ähm, FPS Counter Off, ok, jetzt ist das ja nervig,
das drisst ja ab, weil, exellent, hallo, ich hab das angeklickt, und customize, wie
konnten wir jetzt wieder auf Light theme umschalten, default, jawoll, ok, das sieht ja in Firefox
irgendwie besser aus, zumal die Seite eh in hell dann besser ausschaut, Nupe am Start,
llo, ich hab das, wow, das ist dieses Ryu Mo
Lu des
gar nicht mal so unsinnig weil ich die software am ende auch hauptsächlich unterlinux laufen
lassen will dann ist es natürlich nicht verkehrt wenn man das auch unterlinux programmiert
ja bald ist kobold stream stimmt so ich habe schon vergessen verdrängt besser gesagt
aber wir müssen erstmal einmal git pullern writer monarch s git remote update gibt es da
irgendwas war das hier was gepusht habe echt das letzte das letzte ist es immer aber ist es der
letzte stand den ich gepusht habe omg email adresse liegt nicht schon wieder bei der way auf
der adresse kamer paypal spenden nun ne quatsch das ist keine das ist die offizielle adresse
dir gibt es nichts zu liegen so ich muss den ganzen kram jetzt mal kurz starten client app
so genau ich zeige euch mal wo wir stehen geblieben sind und dann wo wir weitermachen
deff client app surf so erst mal das frontend starten dann wo ich studio code aufmachen
kommet alt dies liegt wird ja immer schlimmer fast ist ja ist ja ist ja nicht auszuhalten nein
alter visual studio manchmal ist es wirklich ätzend ich habe schon 50 milliarden mal gesagt nein aber
das will mir immer sagen möchtest du keine docker extension installieren docker extension
ist das geilste überhaupt du brauchst unbedingt eine docker extension bei der way max habe ich
dir schon erzählt dass du vielleicht die docker extension installieren solltest wie wäre es
eigentlich mal wenn du die docker extension installierst und so eine docker extension ist
schon sehr nice zur abwechslung eventuell mal die docker docker extension installieren soll ich
mal das kannst du alle starten dass ich überhaupt das ganze ausprobieren kann hier wunderbar
läuft alles so starten wir mal das frontend guck mal wo wir hier stehen geblieben sind
ich bin ein noob ich habe sie in der falschen reinfolge gestartet lol
sowas macht man ja auch nicht wäre es mit einer docker extension oh ja ich habe gehört es gibt
eine neue docker extension für visual studio code die ist übrigens nice die docker extension
so jetzt also wir sind an folgender stelle stehen geblieben ich muss die anwendung noch
starten und dann kann ich euch zeigen wo wir stehen geblieben sind und was wir heute noch mal
auf die stelle fertig machen werden weil ich glaube es dauert nicht mehr allzu lang poggers
oh das ist was interessantes taser sagt hier gerade wenn ihr wissen wenn ihr wissen wenn
ihr schnell wissen wollt in den oberflächen stack von einer website wissen wollt könnt ihr
die seite awesome tech stack benutzen nutze dieser teil ok das gucken wir uns an also web
technology stack analysis oh big brain enter web page ok google da kommt dann wahrscheinlich
nichts gescheites raus google benutzt was google benutzt google omg der hessische ist aber nicht
gedacht hätte ich nicht vermutet ehrlich gesagt was verwendet youtube youtube verwendet ok hier
wird schon interessanter google ist ja sehr leicht lightweight google verwendet kaum was
was ist los twitch ist mein stream gekrescht oder ist die viewer anzahl kaputt die viewer anzahl
spackernübels rum es war gerade 5 jahr vorher waren es irgendwie 60 69 jetzt was 5 58 what the
fuck aber das ist tatsächlich ganz interessant guckt mal da da sieht man zum beispiel dass
youtube polymer verwendet polymer verwendet glaube ich außer google keiner mehr das war mal
vor irgendwie gefühlt 50 jahre im halb youtube verwendet reddit ok das war mir jetzt nicht
neu google verwendet python und google font api alles klar ich nutze man schau mit die
drei wm richtig lasst mal gucken der was könnte man ok ok wir gucken mal was da wir gucken mal
was der sebaro verwendet bei wupplo aus punkt tv update knopf ist kaputt aber enter drücken
geht back gefunden jetzt wird jetzt wird analyzed leute huge analyze analyse läuft analyse ha
lull gucken was der sebaro da programmiert hat auf was das läuft stimmt sie bestimmt bestimmt
dass er auch hat die webseite bestimmten c++ gemacht die richtige webseite wupplos punkt tv
übrigens ist https müssen wir müssen wir schon mal korrekt sein hat er sebaro denn eine https
umleitung gemacht ok hat er sehr gut also sebaro wo ist er wo ist der cute mod jquery was ist hier
los weird jam abmahnung ist raus he doesn't know he lacks critical information und die version ist
ach wisst ihr warum das ist bestimmt wordpress oder sowas das müssen aber eigentlich dabei
stehen go here sebaro das ist eine question wenn ich eine dotnet core anwendung auf dem
raspberry pie laufen lassen will muss ich vorher nur die runtime erzählen oder nie gar nicht das
ist mittlerweile total easy du sagst einfach also weder noch du kannst also du hast zwei machen
du kannst die runtime installieren dann ist die anwendung kleiner du kannst aber auch eine
self content anwendung kompilieren die alles mitbringt die auf dem raspberry pie läuft das
einzige was du dazu machen musst ist du gehst in die verzeichnis von der anwendung sagst dort net
bild frag mich nicht aus dem kopf minus c release minus er arm 64 oder bin ich jetzt nicht ob die
ob die sachen stimmen ok arm 64 so vielleicht linux arm kann man das nicht merken ja ok das
funktioniert schon mal sehr gut machst du bei event of code mit nee ist jetzt falsch gemacht
richtig so das ist alles was ach so genau da musst du noch sagen minus minus self contain glaube
ich also das kann microsoft wirklich nicht kommando zeilenprogramme das kann keiner merken was das
für komische ach minus minus self content true ja weil wenn ich selbst content angebe da will
ich natürlich auf falls machen ganz klar ok ich bin zu dumm dafür ach publish es ist gar nicht
bild ich bin ja organisiert publish publish ist es ok alles klar so selbst content jetzt jetzt
also richtig genau das da musst du ausführen und dann kopierst du den ordner auf den raspberry pie
und es läuft so guck dir jetzt diesen ordner hier diesen ordner diesen publish ordner also
dieses ganze schmodder kannst du ignorieren diesen publish ordner kopierst du auf den
raspberry pie und es läuft mehr musst du nicht machen monka sdl excellent es ist auch nicht
monka sdl es ist mona ich kann dich lesen ja du hast recht so ist richtig geschrieben genau weil
du siehst auch daran dass es ein armen projekt ist wenn ich das jetzt versuche auszuführen zum
beispiel ja mona s dann sagt er mir falsches binary weil das ein armbinary ist wie war das
jetzt gut da kannst du deine anwendung cross kompilen für raspberry pie von deinem desktop
rechner aus und jetzt kommt jetzt kopierst du das auf den raspberry pie rüber und dann funktioniert
hat jemand gefragt ich weiß gar nicht mehr wer ist gefragt hat im chat eben hier der der der der
der 1337 wo du natürlich eine sache kann sein dass du dir ein bisschen mehr arbeit machen musst wenn
du irgendwelche native bindings verwendest ja irgendwelche z-geschichten die dir getrennt übersetzen
muss da musst du ein bisschen mehr action machen aber wenn das einfach nur dort net ist und da nicht
selbst kompiliertes dabei ist dann ist kein problem also sprich wenn du einfach mpeg vom
system installiert verwenden ist kein problem das funktioniert überall ja so sieht es aus
habt ihr eigentlich schon mal video geguckt von heute moment der titel von meinem video stimmt
nicht von meinem streben da stehen auch ideen für geschenke für all die noch nichts haben
oder hat einfach mein vorschau fenster nicht aktualisiert ne stimmt doch ok dann stimmt
mein mein twitch nicht wollte erwähnen dass cyberpunk 271 mit 1,1 million viewer hat nice
ja stream dance gaming dann weiß ich was ich nachher kucke ich finde das so geil dass die
erste suche ist denn gaming boyfriend juckt mich überhaupt nicht ehrlich gesagt wie sein
boyfriend ausschaut so zeigt mal her streamt er aber das hat schon gestreamt ok absolut mein
absolut lieblings let's play kann ich mir alles angucken von wenn ich sonst nichts zu tun habe
twitch ist halt pepega aber richtig deswegen war jetzt was anti pepega mäßiges also ich
wollte euch jetzt sagen zeigen wo wir stehen geblieben sind genau also mal gucken ob die
anwendung jetzt startet gut also das letzte mal denn denn denn ist der beste beste let's
play ohne scheiß ich es gibt nicht viele let's play die ich mir angucken kann im deutschsprache
im bereich nicht einen muss ich ehrlich sagen die großen habe ich mir noch nie angeguckt
vielleicht die ein oder anderen einzelnen ausgaben aber im deutschsprachigen bereich
gucke ich mir absolut gar keine let's plays an ich muss euch auch ehrlich sagen das liegt
zum größten da daran weil ich alle deutschen let's player war zumindest die die immer so
vorgeschlagen ich finde das ultra cringe teilweise es gibt ja manche die sind so extrem langsam
die sind so droh was ist das denn hier für eine für einen ein luftschacht in der wand
das gucke ich mir jetzt etwas genauer an guck mal da ist ein gitter an dem luftschatten was das
wohl macht so nach dem motto sachen wo ich in zwei minuten durch sprinte braucht er fünf folgen
ja die dann geht es mir auf den sack dass viele deutsche let's player einfach so die ober ultra
casual sind denn es auch in casual ja denn es auch in casual aber deutsch die sind so ober ultra
let's casual die haben noch teilweise nicht mal eine ahnung was im pc drinne stecken haben an
hardware so nach dem modus habe ich mal bei mediamarkt gekauft so nach dem motto geschweige
denn dass die irgendwie auch was auch nur ansatzweises kompetentes im gaming bereich
von sich geben können also kann ich kann mir deutschlet's player angucken ach ja und dann
hast natürlich natürlich noch die andere geschichten die leute die die ganze zeit übelst
am eskalieren sind ja ihr wisst ich mag danni burnett danni an sich mag ich wirklich aber
let's play videos kann ich mir angucken da kriege ich echt anfälle bei da ist die ganze zeit
in den cut in den komisches gesumme im video und irgendwelche sachen ich nicht lustig finde
halte ich auch nicht aus deswegen dens gaming ist mein absolut lieblings let's player da kann
ich mir fast alles angucken der ist wie gesagt das ist auch ultra casual und langsam aber das
kann ich kann man sich gut angucken ja genau er sind als play noch in mode ja ehrlich gesagt
let's play sind immer in mode das ist das let's plays ist schon so ein so ein so ein standard
ding das ist das da redet man schon gar nicht mehr von das wird einfach noch konsumiert ja
oh das ist durf ein gigabyte variante hast du noch ein dreier bekommen oder weil es gibt
doch glaube ich vom vierer minimale 2 gigabyte oder da vierer nicht minimale 2 gigabyte hast
noch ein dreier bekommen aber das ist nicht schlimm das ist nicht schlimm sino weil du
damit auch mehr oder weniger alles machen kannst oder war das jebait null aber selbst wenn das
ist nicht schlimm das ist nicht schlimm mit einem gigabyte kommst du doch auch super aus du landest
meistens nicht am ram limit bei einem raspberry pi bin noch nicht lange im stream dabei ist
dir windows in a vm oder linux das ist eine gute frage das kommt nämlich öfters ist da rags gg dazu
gar nicht gg eats das ist windows als host und linux in der vm einfach weil es für mich in der
kombination angenehmer ist ja weil alles was ich unter windows mache könnte ich schlecht in einer
windows vm machen und alles was ich unter linux mache kann ich gut unter windows in einer linux
vm machen zum beispiel nicht sachen spielen will mein video editing zeug ein bisschen
bild bearbeitungskram das mache ich einfach unter windows und halt native unter windows weil es am
besten flutscht und mein gebastel mache ich in der linux vm weil das auch nahezu native speed ist
also ich verwende auf der arbeit tagtäglich einen linux ein linux notebook und ich muss dir ehrlich
sagen ich merke keinen unterschied zwischen der vm und dem notebook der einzige unterschied ist
wenn man videos abspielt ja ok aber das war es dann auch dann haben stimmt haben sie erst die
zweite ausgabe auf 248 eingehoben also ich weiß ich habe mir zum release in vierer gekauft noch
noch ein release raspberry pi vier das sind die die ein bisschen usb probleme haben aber ohne
scheiß sollte ich merke das mit cyberpunk ich merke das extrem mit cyberpunk hier guckt mal
also dass jetzt den stream deswegen ausmachen oder so gleich aber guck mal letzten wochen
letzten paar monate der nico der guckt schon so aggressiv hier der spiel spieler cyberpunk
glaube ich nicht oder just chatting der spielt gar nichts mehr wahrscheinlich der spielt biceps
letzte mal hatten wir eigentlich schon instant irgendwie 150 60 wir hatten ja teilweise schon
bei so nischen streams 250 in letzter zeit geht übelst ab und heute cyberpunk bäm aber nicht
ich will ich merke es nur ich merke es halt nur extrem das ledung set ab ist top habe ich auf
der arbeit auch so also ich habe die gleiche config die ich hier habe habe ich auf der arbeit
auf einem notebook auch zum größten teil falls sich interessiert zum größten teil habe ich die
config hier aber die habe ich schon eine weile nicht mehr geupdated aber im großen und ganzen
hat sich auch nicht allzu viel geändert aber wenn es wenn es sich interessiert wie es aufgebaut
ist und ganz hier angucken was habe gerade für 15 euro ein pie model b plus und ein pie 2 modell
bekommt er ja ach so in den respiratory pie 1 oder was war der ist in den respiratory pie 1 kann
sie nicht gebrauchen nicht mehr aber den pie 2 kann es noch gebrauchen das problem ist an
eins und zwei dass sie kein wlan dabei haben die haben kein wlan dabei das ist eigentlich das
hauptproblem wenn du kein wlan brauchst du natürlich kein problem aber das ist ohne wlan ist
keine ahnung wie quake ohne fps so genau also ich zeige euch mal was wir das letzte mal
gebastelt haben und zwar wir sind ja gerade dabei eine anwendung für überwachung kameras zu bauen
die muss ich am anfang des streams immer so ein bisschen zusammenfassen die es ermöglicht möglichst
latency free also mit weniger also mit möglichst geringer verzögerung streams von überwachung
kameras in den browser zu streamen das funktioniert auch schon ziemlich gut also das hat nahezu keine
latency wenn die kamera mitspielt wenn die kamera natürlich intern irgendwie schon zehn sekunden
verzögern kann ich auch nichts machen aber die meisten kameras die sind dann nicht so so also
sprich einmal stream von überwachung kameras möglichst latency freien browser bekommen ist
das erste das zweite ist dass wir dann auf diesem stream machen wir objekterkennung also sprich
wenn leute durch das bild laufen das funktioniert auch schon wenn leute durch das bild laufen dann
erkennt man das und kann darauf reagieren zum beispiel eine aufnahme starten aufnahme starten
funktioniert auch schon macht er aktuell so sobald man sobald eine person erkannt wurde im bild dann
startet er eine aufnahme zehn sekunden rückwirkend macht er das also bisschen so ein bisschen wie
wie shadowplay da buffert immer zehn sekunden und wenn dann einer durchs bild läuft dann nimmt
er die zehn sekunden speichert die auf die platte und nimmt dann ab da weiter auf eigentlich ziemlich
gut ziemlich gut funktioniert das mittlerweile genau und bei jeder weiteren motion erkennung
verlängert das um 30 sekunden so dass da am ende dann ein durchgängiges video hast so lange action
in der kamera war so man kann auch manuell aufnehmen und die sache ist die der chat hat gesagt hey es
wäre doch cool wenn man um neue kameras hinzuzufügen so sieht übrigens der startbildschirm aus wenn man
auch gar keine kamera geedit hat der chat meint es wäre doch cool wenn man irgendwie den wizard
hätte wenn man noch keine kameras hinzugefügt hat oder wenn man neue kameras hinzufügen will
dass man nicht in eine conflict datei muss sondern habe ich dann ok ich baue mal einen wizard wo man
neue kameras hinzufügen kann das heißt das funktioniert auch insofern schon dass das letzte
mal sind wir allerdings nicht allzu weit gekommen dass wenn man auf den button klickt dass man
den assistent bekommt also den wizard dass man name der kamera eingeben kann stream der kamera
und dass man im zweifelsfall auch username password von der kamera eingeben kann dann
klickt man auf continue und dann kriegt man eine vorschau das funktioniert noch nicht im
letzt das hat noch nicht im letzten stream funktioniert mit der vorschau das habe ich
gefixt oft schrieb ja das war ein bisschen verkackt da bekommt man eine vorschau und da
an der stelle machen wir jetzt weiter liegt ja liegt von meinem hoftor woran es lag es lag hier
dran ich kann es immer ganz schnell zeigen wenn man die kamera hinzugefügt hat dann habe ich die
kamera in die datenbank also ich habe zuerst die kamera gestartet und dann die kamera in die
datenbank geschrieben und das heißt die kamera hatte unterschiedliche ids die kamera hat bevor
man sie in die datenbank schreibt immer die id 0 weil es die folg id ist und nachdem man die
kamera in die datenbank schreibt also die details hat es dann die id die die datenbank vergibt und
dementsprechend hat dann das kameramanage verwaltungssystem unter der haube die kamera
nicht mehr gefunden weil die ids unterschiedlich waren aber das haben jetzt gefixt und dann sieht
man das ganze so und an der stelle machen wir jetzt weiter muss man kurz was muss man kurz
hier mein mein beautify zeuge um 2 bildschirm aufmachen weil aus dem kopf kann ich das nicht ihr
wisst ich bin nicht der große frontend hält also wer jetzt vielleicht schon gemerkt hat dass mit
javascript magier im titel bezieht sich nicht unbedingt auf mich weil dann wäre das ganz schön
fertig und wird geil ausschauen also ich würde sagen wir machen jetzt erst mal hier ups jetzt
erst noch mal in das setup rein gucken ob wir das hier noch ein bisschen schöner machen können also
habe ich denn hier den kram beautify so ok also was haltet ihr zum beispiel davon wenn wir hier
anstatt das war relativ mit heißer mit heißer nadel gestrickt das letzte mal was haltet ihr
davon wenn wir das nicht mit einer checkbox machen sondern und jetzt wird es advanced also
aktuell haben wir so eine checkbox die kann man ein häkchen dran machen und dann kann man
user name passport für die kamera eingeben falls die einen braucht was haltet ihr davon wenn wir
da keine checkbox machen sondern eine switch component verwenden das sieht schon gleich viel
nicer aus guck mal hier viel viel web web 5.0 liga checkbox ist oldschool so ein switch ist das was
man heute macht ja switch sieht gleich viel besser aus oder finde ich auch switch ist switch ist
progas so nämlich switch einfach mal mal mal mal mal mal switch draus meinung zum github dark
mode ich habe mir ehrlich gesagt noch nicht angeguckt wollen wir uns mal angucken können
wir machen wo stellt man das überhaupt ein wo stellt man den dark mode überhaupt ein
wir fordert ein t systems werkstudent excellent settings oder kann ich dann hingehen da kann
ich ich gehe nicht auf meine settings hier im stream das kannst vergessen ok wartet mal ich
mache ich mal kurz aus wer weiß was da drin steht ok ich bin zu durf das zu finden
modcheck wo macht man das github dark mode wo gibt es denn das github introduces dark mode ok
zeig her wo ist es ja ja ich stimme ich stimme allem zu ist kein problem ich stimme allem zu
und der appearance in settings aha ok da muss ich noch mal ausmachen das mache ich jetzt wir
machen es dark mode an dark mode ist essential settings appearance ah excellent oh man kann
sogar einstellen sein preferred default emoji skin tone ich bleibe gelb gelb sind die ursprünglichen
emojis beste ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich fand es eigentlich ziemlich gut gelöst dass
die ursprungs emojis eine hausfarbe eine hautfarbe haben die es gar nicht gibt und ich dachte
eigentlich ich dachte eigentlich dass es da deswegen keinerlei notwendigkeit gibt überhaupt
hautfarben in emojis abzubilden weil die standard emojis ja schon eine hautfarbe haben die es
eigentlich gar nicht gibt aber ich habe falsch gedacht das ist ganz essentiell dass wir jetzt
alle möglichen emoji fahren haben aber auf der anderen seite ist ja auch nicht verkehrt
unicode hat genug platz für alle möglichen sachen so übrigens dark mode excellent
doch ganz hübsch aus monac s bestes logo immer noch was sagt ihr zu dem projekt logo ich
finde ich finde das ist schon das ist schon auf einem niveau mit flatter und den besten
projekt logos auf github oder also ich glaube es gibt nicht viele projekt die schöneres
project logo haben als ich das ist schon also das ist schon ganz vorne mit dabei was ist
xps zugucker kenne ich nicht mal du meinst du die notebook den notebook typ ne haben wir
nicht nein nein wir haben abm den ovo ist es jetzt ja wir haben seit jahrzehnten quasi
nur thinkpads in allen möglichen ausstattungen ich finde die dinger nicht übel passt eigentlich
so also wir wollten hier aus dem da wollten wir eine ein switch machen das sieht dann
gleich viel stylischer aus passt mal auf warum refresh dann die automatik guck mal hier ist
es nicht viel schöner mit mit dem mit mit dem switch jetzt so viel viel besser
moment ich muss gerade was gucken ich habe mich irgendwie voll verklickt gerade ich sehe
mich den chat auch gar nicht mehr was habe ich jetzt gemacht ja 0w ach ich ich habe die
die controltaste festgehalten und ab dem aus habt ihr mausgrad bewegt ich habe gerade mein
browser irgendwie auf ein prozent schriftgröße gestellt ich habe gerade warum sieht das so
unglaublich beschissen aus gerade recht pepega action ja das ist voll die weihnachtliche
musik ja ok wir könnten auch ok wir haben jetzt hin und switch wir könnten allerdings
auch ich habe noch eine andere die wir können auch bei der checkbox bleiben und jetzt machen
ich habe mich nachgeguckt wie das ganze funktioniert wir machen jetzt den eiken da vorne dran nämlich
kann ich sagen prepend eiken und dann sagen wir mde lock oder haben wir da haben wir jetzt
hier in checkbox dann steht vielleicht soll ich credentials auch weg machen meinen machen
machen wir irgendwie wie schreibt mein authentification authentification schreibt man das so kann das
immer nicht schreibe so alles klar exzellent aber so irgendwas so wunderbar exquisite optik
jetzt klitscht auch jetzt klitscht auch der checkbox nämlich links rein oder ist es als
switch doch besser ich sollte mich nicht an so viel kleinscheiß aufhalten weil eigentlich
ist das total egal ob das ein switch oder eine text oder eine checkbox ist was ist besser
chat sag mal switch oder checkbox wir machen ist was wir lassen jetzt hier mal den checkbox
an der stelle geht es ja wirklich darum switch ok beides eine eine switchbox dann quasi stimmt
es switcht was ok dann machen wir das so wir könnten übrigens anstatt dem authentification
können wir so ein helfe knopf da wobei ganz ehrlich das label braucht man doch eigentlich
gar nicht oder ich finde das ehrlich gesagt ziemlich selbsterklärend dieses ding hier
mit dem mit dem ding das finde ich eigentlich total selbsterklärend es passt ok checkbox
und dann erscheint der switch ah jetzt ja mag sein aber ich habe es eh gelöscht ok
also fügen wir das mal hinzu jetzt kommt die vorschau gleich soll die vorschau funktioniert
richtig sehe ich gerade die lädt zu langsam das gucken wir uns gleich mal an was da was
das sache ist warum das so langsam lädt aber hier würde ich sagen cancel ah cancel geht
auch nicht ok wir sollten hier vielleicht mal noch eine art überschrift drüber machen
also sowas wie also dass wir hier oben eine überschrift drüber machen mit keine ahnung
irgendwas mit ads oder sowas soll ich mal kurz gucken center und dann wie man typisch
denn hier rum
macht das fragezeichen weg welches fragezeichen
das kabel von maherzeit statt mich gerade da so ich fragezeichen soll ich weg machen
man kann fragezeichen da
der stream ist übelst die laid der stream ist eigentlich ziemlich aktuell warte mal
ich mache jetzt mal 1 2 3 das stream hat zwei sekunden verzögern oder so ok also es war
erst mal weiter vielleicht sollten wir oben drüber noch noch eine überschrift oder was
machen da muss ich mal kurz gucken wie man was centered center moment wie centered man
text center geht das text centered ok selbst drauf kommen können text centered excellent
und dann machen wir irgendwie sowas hier ha ha 6 ne funktioniert nicht ist jetzt irgendwie
verkehrt gemacht alter warum machen guck mal warum macht man so easy sachen so kompliziert
wie machen jetzt eine meine jetzt eine überschrift meine güte ich bin dazu low brain für heading
kann ich meine überschrift machen 1 ist ok hat das plus nicht aktualisiert das problem
aber jetzt als klasse ich habe jetzt als klasse haben aber h1 richtig klasse ist h1
seht ihr leute da geht schon los ich bin zu dumm eine überschrift zu machen in javascript
und css an text center funktioniert aber was man das vielleicht vorne hinschreibe nö gibt's
nicht ist nicht erlaubt da eine überschrift zu machen warum nicht muss ich da irgendwas
spezielles machen oder so das kann doch nicht sein dass es so kompliziert ist eine überschrift
muss ich vielleicht sagen text muss ich sagen text minus h6 oder sowas achja ok alles klar
achja bezüglich javascript.info kennst du wow das ist ja richtig nice ne kenne ich nicht
oder kann sein das schon mal drauf gewesen bin keine ahnung 10h muss man später mal
angucken so also jetzt haben wir überschrift so add camera wunderbar so next das funktioniert
jetzt also jetzt würde ich sagen wenn wir das hinzugefügt haben dann brauchen wir jetzt
einen switch für die motion detection oder sowas würde ich vorschlagen also sprich wir
machen irgendwie sowas wie kopieren wir uns mal den switch oh liegt kopieren uns mal den
switch ich würde sagen wir machen das unten drunter und dann sagen wir materialize icons
und suchen so ein ordentliches icon für raus hast du das video schon gesehen nö a real day
moment das haben wir glaube ich das doch doch das haben wir letztens geguckt das haben wir
letztens geguckt das kenne ich schon das video motion es gibt es gibt glaube ich motion sensor
ein extra genau icon excellent motion sensor brav so zack und jetzt stellen wir noch ein
dass ich hier auf den stead step manuell switchen kann weil ansonsten krieg ich ja anfälle
wenn ich jedes mal eine kamera hinzufügen muss dass es funktioniert so nice jetzt haben
wir hier einen button da kann man motion detection an und aus machen das ist ganz gut dann brauchen
wir noch irgendwie sowas wie hier weiß ich use objekte detect die detection falls immer
hier motion sensor big brain you are poggers ich habe schon wieder mal ein browser resized
ey was ist nett bin da ich bin da einfach zu dumm für warte mal ich mach mal kurz ich
war mal kurz mein forscher browser zu der broser so wie besser jetzt
glaube ich jetzt glaube ich besser ok also jetzt guck mal jetzt können wir hier motion
detection an ausschalten das eigentlich auch schon mal ganz nice dann übergeben wir das
dann setzen wir das hier in der kamera ich habe noch eine idee wir sagen jetzt dass wenn ich
hier drauf klicke auf den switch dann soll er für den video player auch die motion detection
triggern da gibt es hier oben dann auch noch einen icon das sieht dann auch nice aus kam
ist wie heißt das ist motion ist ist objekte detection oder irgendwie habe ich das denn
genannt ist objekte detection enable alles klar das kommt doch keiner drauf gleich moment ist
nicht im model wo schreibe ich das hier gerade rein komplett verkehrt da so gleich so und jetzt
hätten wir das ganze noch mal jetzt kriege ich auch oben den icon wenn ich das an klicke
ha guck mal da habt ihr das gesehen das ist nicht nice krieg sogar im video player angezeigt dass
wir motion detection haben huge o was habe ich nach kaputt gemacht ist noch die feind
schreibe ich jetzt überall anders nennt ja big brain ui so sieht es aus ok das ist doch
jetzt eigentlich schon mal ganz schick jetzt kann man motion detection jetzt kann man motion
detection an und aus so schwer kann es nicht sein es ist spät es ist spät so schwer kann es
nicht sein den kram richtig zu benennen ok jetzt kann man hier hin und her switchen alles gut
so dann sehen wir die forscher ok gut wenn man auf den nächsten bildschirm geht das ist dann
nummer 3 hier so weiter da schreiben wir jetzt hin wir brauchen übrigens noch die überschrift
sieht besser aus überschrift die wir dann irgendwie wie auch immer nennen settings da kommt ja noch
ein bisschen mehr hin ich habe überlegt man könnte sogar da dann einen overlay machen wo
man object detection anmachen will im was hat er jetzt schon wieder verschmerzen also kann ich auf
zwei wechseln und dabei was machen so und jetzt habe ich überlegt hier machen wir jetzt so einen
time picker wo man auswählen kann ob man timer basiert kamera aufnehmen will oder nicht also
sprich da brauchen wir hier bei beautify so einen date picker oder sowas picker picker wo steht
sowas brauchen wir da und jetzt kommt das was eine sache die ich bei material design total hässlich
finde date picker ist ja alles noch ok das ist halt einfach ein kalender ok aber time picker
dies ist so hässlich dann nicht mal google selbstes verwendet
ich glaube die hat so fixe höhe ich will das übrigens eh anders machen captain seeker ich
will dass er erst umschaltet wenn das video geladen ist können wir gleich mal ausbrennen also 25
hunter hunter la ja gut ist auch ich gebe zu ist auch ein bisschen nischen geschichte wenn
program nicht so deins ist dann würde ich vorschlagen ich meine ich freue mich über
jeden der dabei ist und am start ist dankeschön toxi für elf monate nächster monat ist hyper
subscriber angesagt dann guck lieber eine runde cyberpunk so also wir machen es bei date picker
rein soll die dinger sind so hässlich dass nicht mal google den kram verwendet es scheint
mag sein dass es da eine andere variante gibt die haben standardmäßig den dabei wie sieht
eigentlich der hier aus was ich bräuchte ist ein tag in den day picker ich bräuchte in den day
picker war richtig cool weil dann könnte ich auswählen das hier als day picker das hier
wäre cool weil er könnte ich auswählen ob man nur welche wochentage man aufnehmen will also
stellen wir das ding mal ein 24 stunden also keine kokona zeitrechnung hier so
full width keine ahnung was haben wir hier scrollable landscape so das sieht
das scheiße aus oder dieser dieser dieser dieser material design date picker das ist
wirklich ultra hässlicher krab dann haben wir jetzt hier so ein date picker ich mein es
sieht mit dem dachs ihm noch erträglich aus ja Leute ich habe es kaputt gemacht ich habe
irgendwie umgeschaltet auf kokona time und ich weiß nicht wie man zurück ach nee moment
ich bin auf die minuten gegangen alles klar nichts passiert passt das eklig aber ich werde
ihn verwenden weil ich nicht weiß was ich sonst verwenden soll und der ja irgendwo funktioniert
so dann machen wir noch mal den abstand zwischen den buttons unten ein bisschen größer und nachdem
wir hauptsächlich das dritte kratz teilen stelle ich den stepper startmäßig auf drei
dass wir immer das ganze sehen
class aber padding top fünf oder so nee nicht padding margin ist es glaube ich dass es oben
abstand hat genau aber margin top fünf ja das sieht schon ein bisschen besser aus so und hier
machen wir das auch noch das machen wir jetzt erst mal überall das war jetzt erst mal überall
so button button bisschen mehr abstand genau und da unten der kann auch ein bisschen abstand
vertragen button button ja sieht auch schon viel besser aus ok so timer google kalender
echt google kalender verwendet den hier wirklich boah ist das eklig tong juning fragt heimachs
kannst du was zum beruf system elektroniker sagen hat mich als fachinformatiker für system
integration beworben oder angeboten als information elektroniker bekommen ausbildung nee dazu kann
ich gar nichts sagen klingt old school irgendwie weiß nicht ob es old school ist keine ahnung kann
ich wirklich nichts zu sagen by the way wisst ihr was mir noch mal aufgefallen ist ich habe
euch ja schon oft die story erzählt wo ich beim arbeitsamt war und was die mir erzählt haben
damals was ich doch für beruf lernen sollte und sowas im nachhinein ich habe schon oft gesagt was
spaßt ja aber im nachhinein war das genau das richtige ich mache jetzt das was mir spaß macht
und gerade jetzt in der corona krise bin ich froh dass ich sowas gelernt habe wie ich jetzt
gelernt habe und nicht was mit holzverarbeitung nichts gegen leute was mit holzverarbeitung machen
aber es war überhaupt nicht das was ich machen wollte und der arbeitsamt typ der wollte mir die
ganze zeit erzählen ich soll was mit holzverarbeitung machen weißt du was ich heute gelesen habe dass
die gesundheitsämter sich corona zahlen per fax oder per brief schicken was der inline picker wie
stelle ich das dann auf den inline picker inline schreibe ich einfach inline hier rein ich bin
über jeden time picker der besser aussieht als der dankbar inline reinschreiben geht schon mal
nett was ist denn der inline time picker ja keine ahnung wie ich den inline time picker verwende
so wir brauchen übrigens noch start und stopp fällt mir da gerade auf also wir bräuchten quasi
noch noch mal einen ok wir machen noch mal einen switch oben drüber was der ist ganz unten heißt
picker in menu doch genau der gleiche oder doch genau der gleiche hässliche picker
nimmt weniger platzwerk ist eigentlich keine schlechte idee gefällt mir eigentlich ja das
ist eine gute idee also wie vor alter 30 milliarden zeilen ja html für so ein ding von ks what the
fuck wollen die von mir ich lasse es so dass mir zu kompliziert für so ein daytime picker was
ist denn das für ein riesen ding ich meine cool ist es schon wie das auf plop es hat es hat was
menu close und was machen die da das ist ja fünf seiten lang achte müssen beide sachen drin ok
welche welche brauche ich denn picker in ok das ist der dialog den brauche ich nicht brauche
den menu menu das hier brauche ich aber es geht eigentlich ich probiere das jetzt mal ich komme
ich komme paste dass ihr wisst im copy paste bin ich immer echt top also wir kopieren uns
auch mal zwei sachen format 24 landscapes crawlable alles klar was was auch immer close on click nutz die
nutke model menu schlechtes schlechtes erst mal alles mal gucken was wir davon auch brauchen
klar time ok da geht schon mal nichts auf weil ich irgendwelche models nicht drin hab aber das ist
das das ist gut das ist das ist eine gute idee weil da kann ich das hier nämlich start start
nennen und es unten nenne ich stopp es ist dann nicht so fett so also was will der hier vom fau was ist was ist adres
den model gibt es jetzt noch nicht menu menu 2 gibt es nicht ok moment da muss ich noch mal kurz
kurz copy pasten also den date picker da kriegt jetzt erst mal noch click ref menu ok wir brauchen
wir brauchen irgendwas was menu heißt alles klar machen die das hier script falls ok er macht er
macht schon mal irgendwas das ist wirklich mal big brain shit hier bis das bis das funktioniert
so was sagt jetzt time brauche ich auch noch time ist null start time nennen wir das aber mal
start time null weil wir haben auf jeden fall noch end time time start time aber noch mehr
time time time time time so mal gucken ob es jetzt geht ha ok es gibt aber keine fehler mehr
ich habe garantiert irgendwas gelöscht was was wichtig ach ja ich muss das menu ich muss das
menu da oben noch wieder rein machen ref ref menu model menu menu muss ich machen moment das
zu spät leute das ist zu zu low brain bin ich da für um die uhrzeit heute da ist er da ist er der
picker die view fehler meldungen sind tatsächlich ganz ok ja so und jetzt pick ich hier was habe
ich kokona time ok ja das ist nice so also wir stellen es aber um auf format 24 7 landscape und
scrawl ok ja das ist doch das ist ganz nett das gefällt mir das hat doch was kogas so full
width ja ok das heißt wenn ich 6 hat 6 hat picker ist das vielleicht vielleicht stelle ich mal
er nicht auf volle breite was wird hier gebastelt denn assistent damit ich neue cameras anlegen
kann in meiner camera in meiner überwachungs camera überwachungs software die cameras in
browser streamt und ich kämpfe gerade mit java scripts date time pickern ok aber das ist doch
jetzt ganz brauchbar oder finde ich eigentlich ganz hübsch so wie es jetzt ist und jetzt ist
das wie kriege ich das weg wahrscheinlich landscape landscape muss weg machen ok ich muss ich muss
wahrscheinlich full width machen das sieht halt aus wie die android urapp es ist halt material
design ja ok leute dann dann ist es der 6 hat der 6 hat time picker massive time picker excellent
der muss so fett sein dass das beautify das gut findet keine ahnung so also das ist startzeit
so dann kopieren wir das ganze gleich noch mal mit end time menu menu da haben wir startzeit
endzeit wo also das trägt jetzt das gleiche moment ich brauche ich brauche neue sachen also ok
das muss ich jetzt mal ordentlich nennen weil sonst finde ich später nicht mehr menu start time
so dann haben wir menu end time und wir haben start time und end time end time bald 100.000
channel points ja du kannst nichts sinnvolles von machen ist das nicht nice also start time
so dann mal menu start time hoffe ich habs jetzt richtig gemacht menu end time und hier haben wir
end time was sicherlich noch irgendwo referenziert wird so mal gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert
ah ist ich habe ich habe was falsch gemacht heute ich habe irgendwas vergessen ich habe ich habe
irgendwo was falsch gemacht irgendwo habe ich was falsch überschrieben guckt
property menu is not defined warum menu
ach ich bin ja auch ein kacknup ich habe das im falschen kopiert lull ich habe das im falschen
kopiert end time menu start time da wisst ja da wisst ja blöd im kopf geht der jetzt wieder
ok da geht so und jetzt brauche ich das hier menu end time und
dass jetzt funktioniert ja wäre ich aber was hat er jetzt wieder für den menu is not defined
menu end time der rüppel 12 monate dankeschön für die subs das ist ja schon massive subscription
hier wo ist es denn dankeschön für den sub master dom neun monate auch hier excellent
subscription big brain subs am stück noch mal schauen ob es jetzt funktioniert haha guckt mal
hier huge by the way ist es beides ref menu ist das ok ref menu ref menu ich habe ehrlich
gesagt kein plastenschimmer was es hier macht aber ich würde einfach sagen passt schon du
speicherst zweimal starr ja hast recht also start heim so das geht los um 22 uhr 50 warum hat
das ding kein ok knopf da kommt doch keiner drauf dass er einfach rausklicken muss gibt
das gibt es das nicht also also manchmal ist material design wirklich absolut low brain st
haben es bestimmt die gleichen leute ausgedacht wie google class wobei nee kann ich sein google
class hat sich die eine ausgedacht die mit dem google chef dann fremd gegangen ist und jetzt nicht
mehr bei google ist aber es ist ähnlich fail gibt es ja nicht in ok knopf oder sowas die haben
die das hier das gemacht menu ok knopf ist overrated ach hier unten ach im dialog kann
ich ein ok knopf mache aber ich will das doch nicht als dialog ich will das als als menü
warum ist mein mein date picker eigentlich über mein menü und nicht wie bei denen unter meinem
menü was soll das der sagt guck mal mein mein picker ist über mein menü ich will das unter
menü haben warum geht das bei denen und bei mir nicht guckt euch das mal an da muss bestimmt
noch etwas wäre ich mal bei dem alten geblieben spacer offset kannst du einstellen offset ich
verstehe scale transition kann man auch machen das probiere ich jetzt mal aus
ob es habe ich schon ah nice guck doch mal da
funktioniert offset y poza king sagt oh viewtify cool damit mache ich auch kein
projekt ja ich bin ja so mit frontend sachen bisschen auf kriegsfuß aber es ist schon ganz
cool vieles ist aber auch echt massiv umständlich und braucht drei seiten was ich jetzt noch cool
finden würde wenn es den einfachen ok knopf unten hätte aber auch ach guck mal das geht
automatisch zu wenn ich nur zeit aus oder auch nicht eben ging das automatisch zu wenn ich nur
zeit ausgewählt habe am moment habe ich mich da irgendwo vertan
ach hier enter ist das ein krampf meine güte ok ok zack zack zack zack jetzt muss ich da drauf
jetzt ok dann ist das f1 und das ist f2 weiß ich was ich da sonst noch einstellen soll
braucht man das sonst noch irgendwo hier ok menu 1 und dann ist das menu 2
das wie model stimmt nicht echt wo wo ich blick da echt gerade überhaupt nicht mal durch wie
model starteim starteim ist doch alles richtig und enteim enteim ist auch richtig das wie
model ist falsch enteim starteim oder es ist einfach nur riesen delay aha ok die
revs war hey guckt mal jetzt funktioniert es wirklich ganz cool kaum macht man es richtig
funktioniert wer hätte das für möglich gehalten auch ja das ist eigentlich ganz schick hier muss
ich sagen ok cancel macht noch nichts aber das ist cool das gefällt mir das hat was ok also
so jetzt muss ich noch einstellen dass ich hier den switch haben will switch switch wir können
gar nicht mal zu lang weitermachen weil man switch drüber ob wir das überhaupt haben wollen
irgendwie mde mde clock oder sowas gibt es glaube ich und dann sagen wir jetzt hier use
timer klick mal weg label brauchen wir auch nicht dann ist das hier wisst ihr was ist hier was wir
noch machen können was hat er jetzt wieder verschmerzen also use timer ist not defined ich
habe noch eine idee was wir machen könnten könnten gucken dass das vielleicht nebeneinander
dargestellt wird wenn das so groß ist ich hab da hab ich die ich hab eine idee ich hab
nie nehmen mal gucken ob es ob es kugel aufs funktioniert vielleicht soll ich da auch noch
ein paar komponenten draus machen weil es doch ein bisschen lang wird langsam so use timer ok
das funktioniert so und jetzt können wir noch was machen ich hab ich hab eine idee also sagen
view row ist das glaube ich um das ganze drum herum so alter lauprein was ist mit denen los hier
gut es ist glaube ich nicht so gedacht sollte damit nicht eigentlich klar kommen
sollte damit da kommt damit klar
perfekt kann man nicht sowas sagen wie
klasse wie ging es jetzt justify
justify space around oder irgendwie sowas wenn du das lanscape raus aber ich mag mich
für das lanscape ist nice der soll das gefällig skalieren
einerseits
lanscape heute heute lern ich hier was was ist wenn ich noch kleiner mache wenn ich noch kleiner
macht zeigt er nur einen an also wirklich gut funktioniert das net macht es wieder rückgängig
das war ich nicht ja so ist so ist besser so use timer aber können in diff drumherum machen dass
ich das mit einem ein und ausschalten kann use timer ok ok ok post jam post jam funktioniert
ganz gut ok damit bin ich jetzt damit bin ich zufrieden leute mehr mehr brauche ich
erst mal net um glücklich zu sein was das angeht alles klar so als kann ich startzeit
endzeit auswählen zack zack sehr gut sehr sehr nice das gefällt mir ausgesprochen
nice du ich muss avira jetzt den
installieren auf dem zweiten rechner ich weiß gar nicht warum ich den crap da überhaupt noch
drauf hab das nervt schon wiederum mit mit irgendeinem müll
all gehe weg weg avira ist richtige richtige low brain software
das ist das mit dem regenschirm was jetzt an kaspersky oder so verkauft wurde oder an
irgendwas anderes von vor ein paar tagen
nee nee bei mir ist nichts vor installiert das habe ich da vor fünf jahren mal selbst
darauf installiert oder sechs jahre auf dem zweiten rechner
zwar eine doofe idee aber damals hat man sowas noch gemacht norton aber norton ist
doch auch nicht mein norton norton gehört doch irgendjemand anderem oder
oder ich kann mir denken heute ist das zu viel ich bin zu spät so zeug zu machen hier also
wir fangen erst mal mit dem stepper wieder von vorne an
ok zack jetzt fügt das hinzu jetzt kann ich motion detection an machen continue kann
ich einen timer vergeben gut
alles klar das ist doch eigentlich ganz nice gefällt mir so dann heißt das letzte nicht
continue sondern finish continue
aber hier noch jetzt finish
und so und jetzt müssen wir noch eine sache gucken fällt mir gerade an also das geht mir
nämlich ein bisschen zu das ruckelt mir ein bisschen zu sehr hier das heißt wenn ich
das hier adde ich hätte erst mal gerne ein bisschen feedback was überhaupt schief geht
aktuell kriegt man da überhaupt nichts mit also sprich wenn ich was hinzufüge was nicht
funktioniert zum beispiel das da dann schmeißt ein fehler geht trotzdem über also das muss
auf jeden fall abfangen das heißt add camera muss da muss irgendwie noch muss irgendwie
noch eine logik rein to do warum kackt das ab wenn die kamera da ist ja das haben wir
gefixt so also das heißt ich muss jetzt erst mal gucken was da zurückkommt
wenn ok ok also sprich hier mach ich den request um die kamera anzulegen wenn der request nicht
ok ist
result
oder umgedreht wenn wenn das result ok ist dann mache ich diesen ganzen schmodder hier
so loading falls mache ich im beiden fällen ok ok
so dann muss ich noch irgendwie den fehler setzen ganz schön voll hier so wenn man den
fehler haben dann wird der button einfach rot so und das heißt das nennen wir auch nicht
kontinue sondern das nennen wir keine ahnung create oder add und machen es grün so nach
dem motto hier bärm hier kannst du was hinzufügen und das wird dann rot wenn es einen fehler
gibt
so jetzt macht das schon mal nicht weiter das ist schon mal gut so jetzt setze ich noch
den fehler
wenn das nicht ok ist dann error gleich true und ansonsten ist hier auch falls es vorher
mal einen fehler gab ist der error wieder falls wenn es dann doch geklappt hat beim
zweiten durchlauf oder so sprich jetzt gibt es einen fehler und ich kann den button einblenden
für error
das heißt diesen button zeige ich nur an bei keinem error und den button zeige ich nur
an bei error so und der ist jetzt auch red wenn es den error gegeben hat ob das jetzt
halbwegs funktioniert was ajax jquery what ne ne was achso doch doch fetsch fetsch meckert
hier irgendwie achso jetzt kann ich nicht testen weil ich bin lowbrane ich habe den
gültigen stream ergeben ah guck mal funktioniert so guck jetzt kann ich adden und es geht nicht
und wenn ich das jetzt ändere auf was gültiges und noch mal klicke dann clearte hoffentlich
den error und geht weiter
ah doch schick ui design eins plus hier ich glaube guck mal es gibt ja auch einen fehler
man kann das bestimmt mit einem try catch oder so machen das ist ja so die übliche
java script geschichte denke mal dass du da wieder alles auf 30 verschiedene varianten
machen kannst ok das ist nice das gefällt mir jetzt
müssen wir nur noch fixen dass das so langsam lädt so und das problem ist da folgendes
ähm wenn ich hier auf add drücke dann geht das zum server was da los oh ich glaube ich
habe da einen bug drinnen oh ich sehe es auch wo der bug ist ich musste stoppen wieder
bei einem fehler chat seid ihr das ich musste stoppen bei einem fehler
der chat ist es ich wusste es ich wusste es ich musste stoppen bei einem fehler
gehackt wie feier ei ja das habe ich vorhin auch gelesen ich weiß zwar nicht was feier
ei genau ist aber ich habe beheise heute morgen gelesen dass feier ei gehackt ist
aber gucken ob es jetzt besser funktioniert wenn ich da was reinschreiben was kaputt ist
der stoppt das nicht feier ei ist eine security bude scheint ja äußerst secure zu sein wahrscheinlich
sind die genauso secure wie bitconnect den leuten geld gebracht hat kommt wahrscheinlich
gleich aus so ähm was ist da was habe ich da lowbrain mäßiges programmiert warum
stoppt er das jetzt ich die was die bauen zeugs für die cia ok da ist ja auch jemand
das war es aber mal der soll das stoppen wenn er einen bett request zurück gibt warum stoppt
er das nicht bei einem bett request was wird das monarch s projekt eigentlich das ist
eine software mit der du deine überwachung kameras in den browser streamen kannst inklusive
objekterkennung ob personen durchs bild laufen oder nicht und wenn personen durchs bild laufen
kann er aufnehmen kannst aber auch manuell aufnehmen oder timer gesteuert aufnehmen
oder sowas klingt gut ja ist finde ich ist auch ist auch nice ok ok ok leute warum stoppt
er das nicht was mache ich denn hier verkehr habe ich habe ich auch das richtige richtige
ausgecheckt habe ich habe ich den aktuellen stand überhaupt hier drauf so man so auf nummer
sicher zu gehen man weiß ja nie glaub schon stopp keck w ist das letzte letzte kommet
von gestern irgendwann ok warum stoppt denn ich mache ich sage hier ok ich sage start
wenn es einen fehler gibt mache ich sage ich vorher stopp ich muss es nur aus der datenbank
löschen aber daran sollte das eigentlich nichts nicht liegen remove kamera breakpoint rein
oder breakpoint da müsste man mit dem debugger was machen achso man muss ja oh ja da muss
das jetzt so warum stoppt er das lass mal kurz lass mal kurz in mich gehen der startet
das oder starte das hier das macht er immer und man sollte ich weiß woran das liegt max
low plane programming ich weiß woran das liegt das liegt gar nicht an das ist alles
vollkommen richtig aber was ich hier gebastelt habe sagt also das kann man das kann man gar
nicht richtig abbrechen und zwar das einzige was er was er beim abbrechen macht ist cancel
gleich also cancel auf true zusetzen was der natürlich nicht macht ist überhaupt zu
checken ob ich gekanzelt habe das cancel macht einfach grad bis auf eine stelle gar nichts
schaue mich nicht so die schabe ach das ist weil ich die testversion verwende da habe
ich die rege leuchte pass mal auf jetzt funktioniert es jetzt funktioniert jetzt ich darf es doch
nicht enden ich muss was enden was nicht funktioniert fehlgeschlagen warning jetzt dürfte er sich
noch genau es connecte dass ich noch einmal aber macht dann nichts mehr jetzt ist jetzt
vorbei genau der sagt es noch connectin dann geht er hier dann erkennt er dass es cancel
ist und dann ist gut ok sehr schön zumindest zumindest beim fehler kackt jetzt das back
end nicht ab richtig richtig low brain was ich da programmiert hab ok so und jetzt wenn
es fehlgeschlagen ist kann ich einfach was eintragen was richtig ist leg noch mal add
und es funktioniert so jetzt muss ich nur noch dafür sorgen dass das hier mit dem laden
ein bisschen besser funktioniert so und das problem ist also sprich wenn ich jetzt hier
was adde und zack zack zack so und jetzt jetzt macht er hier erst die verbindung es wäre
schöner wenn der beim also bevor der switcht dass der das dann schon geladen hat also dass
der quasi unten noch sein loader drinne hat das wäre schöner das heißt ich muss irgendwie
rausbekommen wenn der connected ist wie kriege ich dann raus wenn der connected ist ich mache
schon a weight connect also der baut jetzt war die verbindung zum server auf für das
video da wartet auch bis diese verbindung aufgebaut ist das macht halt nicht weiter
bis die verbindung aufgebaut ist das problem ist nur dass das zwei paar schuhe sind ob
die verbindung zum server aufgebaut ist oder ob genug bild infos da sind dass der video
player was anzeigen kann das heißt ich muss jetzt in meinen video player irgendwie einbauen
dass der sagt wenn er gestartet ist ok jetzt wird jetzt wird es etwa also wir bauen jetzt
in video player ein dass der bescheid sagt ob er gestartet ist und das machen wir über
irgendein custom event von view view custom event set timeout ich werde wahrscheinlich
jetzt auch wirklich was set timeout machen um zu ach so ging das genau ich mache jetzt
wirklich set timeout um zu gucken was der video player für den state hat und was ich
davon vielleicht abgreifen kann ich sehe hier ist auch noch ein bug drin guck mal ich kann
die control elemente einblenden das will ich gar nicht das muss ich auch noch schnell
fixen da habe ich aber schon was eine variable für angelegt die sich nämlich ist interactive
oder so nennt video player hier muss ich nur noch mal muss ich nur noch mal setzen wie
heißen die ist inter ist interaktiv ok ist ist interaktiv ist immer falls bäm so jetzt
kann ich jetzt auch keine menüs mehr hier drin aufmachen die ich dort nicht aufmachen
will was ist interaktiv falls ach so jetzt muss ich hier noch checken ist ist interaktiv
und dann machen wir das ansonsten machen wir das nicht jetzt richtig geschrieben immer
neu laden post champ pausierung champ ok es ploppt nichts mehr auch sehr gut aber das
geht immer noch mit dem motion sensor alles gut alles klar ok jetzt kommen wir mal zurück
zu dem custom event was ich einbauen wollte also wir machen jetzt ein custom event wenn
der player played playing so und das schmeißt jetzt kein playing wie wurscht wie das heißt
jetzt ist nur die frage wie ich das auslösen kann ich weiß dass der video player video
player haben event für playing aber das kann ich nicht verwenden weil der video player
noch gar nicht geladen ist also im twin ist nicht so dass er played kann er erkennen ob
ein mensch oder ein auto ist also menschen erkennt er ziemlich zuverlässig ich hab jetzt
leider keine kamera drin mit der ich es ausprobieren kann aber das haben wir schon ausprobiert
menschen erkennt er ziemlich zuverlässig und malt dann so einen lila rahm drum guck das
kann ich dir zeigen wie das aussieht deshalb muss zeige ich dir einfach mal im letzten
oder in einem der letzten streams aber wenn du spannend findest ist nice wo haben wir
denn hier wo haben wir denn hier gebastelt mal gucken ich glaube irgendwie am anfang
hier sieht man es nochmal ach nee da ist man guck hier hier sieht man es so hier siehst
du die kamerabilder und wenn jetzt ein durchs bild läuft kann sein dass das kaputt ist
weil ich hab das letztens hab letztens kaputt gemacht ne irgendwie wo sieht man das denn
hier schön los warten bis ein durchs bild läuft bis ich es zeige ok jetzt ich glaub
jetzt hab ichs gefixt da jetzt warte mal bis einer durchs bild läuft hier dann siehst
es gleich postchamp ha guck so sieht es dann aus wenn eine
person durchs bild läuft also die person erkennt er relativ gut das ding ist auch hauptsächlich
auf personen trainiert also der erkennt auch schon mal schraubendreher als baseballschläger
und meine katze hat er mal als hund erkannt also so zuverlässig bei objekten ist der
nicht aber der erkennt menschen ganz gut der ist auch hauptsächlich auf menschen trainiert
ist es halt bei diesem ganzen machine learning zeug immer ganz entscheidend davon abhängig
mit was für trainingsdinger man das trainiert hat so genau ich wollt jetzt mitkriegen wenn
das playing ist so wie bekomm ich denn mit ob der player playing ist ich werd erstmal
bei einem ad den stepper nicht weitermachen und wirkt dann sehen was ja ja aber schraubendreher
erkennt als baseballschläger ich mein die sieht auch recht ähnlich aus wenn das da
dran ist mein in raspberry pi case hat er mal als bett erkannt ja aber menschen erkennt
er ziemlich gut so also wenn ich jetzt hier ad drücke dann edit die kamera aber macht
nix das ist gut da kann ich jetzt nämlich ausprobieren ob der playing oder was der
macht so dann geben wir dem ding mal eine id layer und wir machen jetzt das wo sich
wahrscheinlich der chat wahnsinnig drüber freuen wird weil das eben schon gespoilert
hat mounted set intervall tausends this und wie geht das revs so und jetzt gucken gehen
wir das mal aus was der player so treibt player da muss ich jetzt nachgucken html video player
methods weiß ich was das hat was man da alles abrufen kann keine ahnung also track audio
source endet duration duration ist glaube ich schon mal nicht verkehrt oh gott please
no warum wegen set interval interval warum das ist zum ausprobieren das geht schon ok
player duration ok guck mal ob das mit duration schon mal was wäre was man woran man erkennen
kann dass das ding abspielt nun infinity aha ok das ist jetzt java strip logik aber das
funktioniert es ist not a number wenn es nicht geladen ist und es ist infinity wenn
der video player nicht geladen ist aber genug material zum abspielen hat alles klar java
script ok in ordnung das könnte man schon mal verwenden gibt es nicht noch in den event
gibt es nicht noch in den event was ich abgreifen kann weil das mit so einem set intervall
alle sekunde gucken und dann breaken und das ist schon ganz schön kacke can play event
fires when the boss ken kennste ah guck mal da oh der chat wieder excellent big biggest
brain chat alles platzt ja schon fast so ok dann dann probieren das jetzt mal aus also
can play excellent schwabenwissen ja manchmal ist der chat wirklich oder also mein chat
ist ja immer hilfreich aber manchmal ist mein chat so hilfreich dass da ganz der twitch
gesamt chat schon zu ab und zu hilfreich wird so viel brain ist hier das wiegt quasi die
restlichen twitch chat auf also habe ich jetzt den video player da video sprich can play
event ok durations und die feind ja jetzt nervt man nicht rum playing log ok schauen
wir mal ob das jetzt was bringt add ne also can play funktioniert schon mal nicht ich
habe es ja auch falsch gemacht da muss ja auch ein add davor dass es ein event ist also
nochmal komando zurück add so play das funktioniert der chat ich glaube es nicht exquisite was
machst du da ich baue gerade einen assistent in meine software ein wo man kameras hinzufügen
kann und zwar wir haben jetzt schon über 1 2 streams ein bisschen an der software rum
gebastelt mit der man sich über wachungs kameras in den browser streamen kann nahezu
ohne verzögerung und gleichermaßen objekte erkennen kann ob da menschen zum beispiel
durchlaufen im im bild und so was nachdem keiner bockhand konfig datei von hand zu editieren
gibt es jetzt ein assistent wo man neue kameras hinzufügen kann so das heißt ich bin nicht
der javascript zauberer der wizard ist der javascript zauberer so also das ist eine richtig
gute idee was der chat hier gehabt hat das muss man echt mal sagen so playing dann emitten
wir das playing event dann machen wir den mounted set interval wieder weg ja jetzt mit
craftql ehrlich gesagt das mit craftql habe ich nur aus einem grund eingebaut nämlich
für subscriptions dass ich easy mit bekomme auf dem client wenn kameras oder aufnahmen
also wenn kameras hinzugefügt werden und wenn aufnahmen gestartet werden und im hinblick
dessen dass wenn leute vielleicht ihre kameras aufnehmen und dann irgendwann mal 5000 aufnahmen
haben mit jeweils 30 sekunden dass man die besser filtern und durchsuchen kann weil filtern
und durchsuchen über rest muss dann alles von hand machen und mit craftql ist schon
eingebaut was ist denn craftql das ist eine abfragesprache eine ab so eine api abfragesprache
also du machst du sagst nicht einfach wie bei rest get get keine ahnung recordings und
kriegst eine liste mit allen recordings und kameras du kannst ganz spezifisch sagen was
du haben willst du kannst zum beispiel sagen hier ich query jetzt alle aufnahmen die zur
zeit laufen von dieser kamera gut das kannst du mit rest auch machen aber da musst du
halt viel von hand basteln dafür dass es funktioniert und als in der antwort möchte
ich allerdings nur drinstehen haben ob es aktiv ist was die aufnahme ausgelöst hat
name der aufnahme und die id von der kamera von der aufnahme das ist mal ursprünglich
von facebook entwickelt worden um ihre tracks mobile ab schneller zu machen ist kein witz
wenn ihr nachguckt sql für rest das trifft es erstaunlich gut ja das haben sie sich
bei facebook aus den fingern gesorgt weil ihre mobile apps sagt also man könnte sagen
es ist von facebook also boomer technologie das ist ein bisschen so was wie outdata ist
ziemlich ähnlich der rüppel hier du bist ja first time subscriber hier für die first
time first also einer der ersten 20 subscriber gewesen richtig nice ich sehe dich total
also ich wie sagt der name gar nicht so viel im stream ich sage ich weiß vielleicht bist
er einfach im chat nicht so aktiv oder so aber guckst aber schön dass du da bist und
dass du schon so früh subscript subscripte subscribesort hast richtig exzellent die facebook
app ist immer noch schlechter gut facebook ist ja auch müll facebook ist so was was
wahrscheinlich irgendwie heute irgendwelche rentner verwenden oder so subscribesort ja
ist da ist ich fällt mir nur gerade auf weil der name sagt mir nicht so viel aber wenn
du halt so quasi einer der ersten einer der ersten subscriber bist dann musst ja schon
ziemlich früh am start auch gewesen sein so also moment jetzt habe ich ganz den faden
verloren was wollte ich jetzt machen ich wollte so eine sache machen genau also so jetzt bekommen
wir mit ob das abspielen funktioniert das heißt wir subscriben uns jetzt zu diesem event
playing machen hier nochmal eine methode play oder nicht brauchen wir nicht wir setzen
einfach den stepper auf zwei das reicht da drin stepper auf zwei ich meine es zwar nicht
so schön inline zu machen aber ein scheiß drauf so und jetzt bin ich ja mal echt gespannt
funst habt ihr das gesehen jetzt ist jetzt haben wir keine ladezeit mehr also wir haben
noch genauso viel ladezeit wie vorher aber das fällt nicht mehr so auf sobald es geendet
ist sobald es geendet ist switch drüber übrigens wir sollten hier noch loading auf falls stellen
und das da unten raus machen das inline zu machen ist vielleicht nicht schön aber funktioniert
jetzt das loading jetzt erst dann ausgemacht wird allerdings beim error muss man es auch
vorstellen alkoholics ist auch heute nischenprogramm ja also wenn es sich interessiert wir haben
schon in ein paar streams eine anwendung gebastelt wo man überwachung kameras ist sich in browser
streamen lassen kann außerdem habe ich auch keinen genauen plan was ich mache das stimmt
und jetzt bastel ich gerade ein assistent dass man mit einer kamera hinzufügen kann wenn
wir jetzt zum beispiel hier auf start gehst und siehst du die ganzen kameras mit denen
ich getestet habe hier guck ganz ganz ich habe ganz schön viele hinzugefügt meine
sind wir der gleiche ausschnitt so und das ist quasi jetzt ein fake bild von der kamera
bei mir weil ich keinen bock habe die echte kamera hier im stream zu zeigen was live in
den browser gestreamt wird von der kamera also es ist ein fake bild insofern ich habe
quasi einen server erstellt der das aufgezeichnete kamerabild ausliefert halt wie als wäre
eine kamera ja und du kannst leute erkennen also wenn ich das einschalte irgendwie den
gründen gerade nicht funktioniert ah ich weiß was ich verkehrt gemacht habe ich muss
hier sagen video player ist interaktiv gleich true und jetzt nämlich nicht du wirst ja
mal ein overlay kriegen ja ok jetzt passt genau guck du kannst jetzt beispielsweise
auch gar das kamerabild aufnehmen wenn du willst manuell oder du kannst es per hier
motion erkennung machen da muss ich nur mal gucken mit dem motion detection das habe ich
gerade nicht eingeschaltet das mache ich jetzt mal in dem assistent noch mal schnell
drinnen objekte detection enabled einfach dass das mal gesehen hast at camera das muss
ich im backend machen ich mache das einfach mal dass man es jetzt sieht hast du das nicht
vor ausschalten weil du es nicht wolltest richtig ich will es jetzt auch nicht ich will
das nicht dass es standardmäßig anders ich will dass das nur per hand eingeschaltet
werden kann aber damit ich jetzt im stream mal zeigen kann mache ich jetzt mal kurz an
so also wenn man die anwendung frisch startet ist noch keine kamera hinzugefügt dann sagt
man ok kamera hinzufügen dann fügt man eine kamera hinzu mit den werten die man braucht
gibt user an was auch immer fügt die kamera hinzu
schaltet motion erkennung ein und sagt finish finish finish doch nicht wirklich aber wir
tun jetzt so als hätte finish gefinished gehen auf die startseite und sehen wir haben
eine kameralauffen motion erkennung und wenn jetzt einer durchs bild läuft wirst du gleich
sehen sagt er hier läuft eine person durchs bild und jetzt jetzt könnte man beispielsweise
eine aufnahme anwerfen 30 sekunden mit 10 sekunden buffer vorher dass das aufgezeichnet
wird mache ich das aber wieder aus so da fällt mir bei der gelegenheit noch ein wenn man
hier finished ist beim setup wie nenne ich den knopf im setup am besten finish finished
oder oder completed oder finish wenn es finish gut ist so und confirm na confirm ist ja gebaited
weil so wirklich confirmed ist es ja nicht es ist eigentlich schon confirmed wenn man
den ersten add knopf drückt hier kannst du nur noch ein paar settings ändern zusätzlich
und wenn du cancel machst löscht das wieder ok ok aber wir können noch einstellen dass
er wieder zurück dass er wieder zurück auf das start startbildschirm geht wenn man auf
finish drückt zwar push route slash so so submit ja es ist ja eigentlich schon submitted
ist ja eigentlich fake finishes probier maß mal aus so hinzufügen continue finish und
jetzt geht er auf den startbildschirm und lädt die kamera ich gerade hinzugefügt habe
so jetzt kann man mal gucken was auch wirklich funktioniert fügen wir noch mal eine zweite
kamera hinzu die jetzt 0w heißt hinzufügen es ist insofern fake weil hier wird die kamera
schon submitted und hier kannst du nur ein paar settings finishes ganz ok so und dann
speichern wir es er geht auf die startseite und lädt auch die zweite kamera guck die
kamera heißt 0w und die kamera heißt garten das ist die erste kamera die ich hinzugefügt
habe das ist die zweite kamera die ich hinzugefügt habe ok nice das gefällt mir jetzt schon
echt echt gut gibts jetzt eigentlich nix mehr großartig was man machen müsste oder
so edit table schreiben wir wieder raus dass da keiner zwischen rumklicken kann so wenn
ich mist hinzufüge da gehts nicht wenn ich was hinzufüge was stimmt dann kann man adden
die leadcam wäre gut hier das gibt es dann hier im overlay ja gut cancel cancel sollte
den kram noch löschen genau cancel sollte den kram noch löschen das ist richtig das
wäre natürlich nicht verkehrt also gehen wir mal hier da wo cancel drin steht cancel
komm wir haben schon eine remove camera knopf ich wusste ich gar nicht dass wir den schon
mal eingebaut haben ok aber wir nennen das nicht remove camera wir nennen das cancel
so also cancel gibts hier nen event cancel es gibt hier nen cancel event irgendwo da
unten gibts nen cancel event remove camera remove camera haben wir tatsächlich ach guck
mal haben wir sogar schon eingebaut lull da müssen wir aber noch vorher checken if camera
gleich gleich null weil beim ersten schritt ist die camera noch nicht gesetzt dann machen
wir nichts wobei nee schwachsinn wollen wir nicht wenn es ungleich null ist dann machen
wir was weil wir wollen auf jeden fall zurück wechseln auf die startseite das wollen wir
so und so machen so ok das müsste jetzt eigentlich funktionieren also ich füge was hinzu so stell
fest a sacked doch nicht ich drücke cancel wow klick what achso es heißt ja auch cancel
nicht remove camera null ich habs vorher unbenannt ja ok also hinzugefügt cancel er
geht zur startseite und es ist weg und ah oh äh löscht er das doch nicht wenn man cancelt
stopp er löscht es nicht wenn man cancelt delete haben wir hier sowas drinne delete
er macht da was ok
pock add und jetzt cancel wo kommt das da unten her und warum geht es nicht ok an sich
funktioniert die sache schon mal die pock pock kam ist nicht drinne was ist das oh jetzt
habe ich schon zwei sachen da unten ok das mit dem delete ach ich bin ja auch dumm ich
löscht das nicht aus der datenbank guck mal da ich muss das da noch machen hier stopp
und remove so äh jetzt funktioniert das auch hab das überhaupt nicht gelöscht oh jetzt
jetzt klappt es jetzt steht da jetzt sind auch keine über jetzt sind auch keine überreste
mehr da drin ok jetzt sind die cameras wieder leer ok sagen wir add was passiert wenn ich
jetzt cancel drück das natürlich doof ich quasi cancel drück während es endet dann
macht er mit dem add noch weiter das heißt ich sollte ich sollte den cancel button deaktivieren
oder dafür sorgen dass das nicht geht schöner wäre es dafür zu sorgen dass man nicht in
diese doofe situation kommen kann der add button ist schon deaktiviert guck der add
button macht nix sobald er loading ist ist er schon deaktiviert tja also ich mein wir
können natürlich sagen ok cancel button wo sind wir hier cancel button der ist einfach
äh disabled solange loading ist das ist halt echt cool an view ne dass sowas funktioniert
guck jetzt ist er disabled während das loading ist easy das ist das ist der das ist der schnelle
fix der aber wenn es einer drauf anlegt nicht funktioniert weil wenn einer einfach den
back button zwischendrin klickt dann ist dann geht es halt trotzdem nicht aber ich glaube
das können verschmerzen ja ich würde sagen das haben wir dann dann funktioniert der zauberer
jetzt zauberer funktioniert guckt zack zack timer einstellen wobei die timer sachen werden
noch gar nicht übergeben ne dann finish und da sind wir nice sehr schön gut dann können
wir uns ja in einem der nächsten streams mal den wirklich interessanten dingern widmen
zum beispiel eine übersicht machen für die ganzen aufnahmen die gestartet wurden ach
ja und wir brauchen dann irgendwie noch einen edit knopf für kameras das wo man kameras
löschen und editieren kann das braucht dann aber kein wizard mehr sein sondern einfach
so eine form untereinander und gut ist das schauen wir uns dann das nächste mal an was
macht denn so mein video haben es ein paar leute geguckt gar nicht so viele aber gut
was interessiert schon weihnachtsgeschenke werttur von der baustelle im karten durch
den schnee gestellt dieses teil schöner baustellen stellt nach dem besuch vom all
you can eat chinesen die leute sind auch teilweise echt in 2011 hängen geblieben aber ist ja
nice
hab doch gesagt im video für das da ist als usb stick ersatz affiliate cash naja komm ich
hab auch vier stunden oder oder länger an diesem video rum gewurstet kann ja ein bisschen
affiliate cash abgreifen ja der hat recht ab isoliert sein ist das
beste hier ist ja big plane elektrotechnik manch mensch am start der hat aber recht
die leute haben probleme man kann sich über alles beschweren man kann sich echt über
alles beschweren dann setze ich nicht vier fünf stunden hin und machen video mit meiner
an sich nach wirklich guten tips für für weihnachts bestellen man kann sich echt über
alles beschweren ey beigeschmack ich darf aber alles beschweren weihnachten ist früher
poggers max was meinst du sagt alter wenn verwenden vpn also so oft wie das video schon geguckt
oder verdiene ich damit 5 euro oder so ich würde mit direkt 50 meter isoliertes kabel
bestellen zum ab isolieren ja würde ich auch so machen bambam bambam kannst den ganzen
tag ab isolieren mit dem ding der raspberry pi 4 mit acht gigabyte ist die hardware vorbereitung
für nein das eine hat mit dem anderen überhaupt nichts zu tun du kannst doch in vielen sechst
spieler spielen auch auf dem ein zweifelsfall auf dem ein gigabyte links laufen lassen
aber mit dem anderen gar nichts zu tun der bbq sauce gespiegelt ja das stimmt aber da
war alles teuer in der richtung wenn ich überlege ich habe den großen fail gemacht mir eine
zwei terabyte sd ssd bestellt für 750 euro vor ein paar jahren 750 euro für eine zwei
terabyte ssd heute kriegste die für ein drittel oder für ein viertel oder so voll verschissen
monka es soll ich hoffe ich habe im chat nichts übersehen hast du eigentlich tatsächlich
weibliche zuschauer wenn du immer jungs und medels hast bestimmt vereinzelt aber nicht
viele also laut statistik irgendwie frag mich nicht 3,1 prozent oder so aber davor sind
wahrscheinlich die meisten auf weg gekämpft von der mutter verwendet keine ahnung ganz
ganz vereinzelt nicht viel aber muss er doch ehrlich sagen dass ich jetzt weder die krassen
fitness biceps videos mache noch irgendwelche dinger was jetzt so viele weibliche zuschauer
anzieht noch bin ich irgendwie keine ahnung 22 stehe vor der kamera und sehe nett aus
das wäre vielleicht auch eine sache warum medels an start kommt für videos aber bei
mir sind die nicht am start ne ja vor hätte der friseur das vor ein paar jahren gemacht
der hätte bestimmt 90 prozent weibliche zuschauer gehabt jetzt ist er auch schon zu alt aber
er ist damals gemacht wunderbar der hätte sein der hätte sein beauty zeug weiter machen
muss ich sag es euch hätte friseur sein beauty kram weiter gemacht der wäre der wäre heute
der größte männer youtube beauty youtuber was vielleicht doch mal den onlyfans erkommen
natürlich natürlich das bringt es auch bestimmt onlyfans da kann ich dann meine moment meine
jeb pics reinstellen oder wie was macht man auf onlyfans außer sowas dann kopieren wir
da irgendwelche tentakel geschichten ich weiß nicht was man auf onlyfans macht ich
habe noch nie ohne scheiß leute ich hatte noch nie einen onlyfans account auch nicht
als als wie nennt man das follower ja also sprich ich habe keine ahnung wie onlyfans
von innen aussieht ich hatte auch nicht mal den belldelfin aber nein ich hatte nichts
von irgendwo hab keine ahnung warum warum eigentlich onlyfans wahrscheinlich weil patreon
kein porn zeug erlaubt oder oder warum haben die jetzt alle onlyfans das muss doch irgendeinen
grund haben sonst hätte sich das doch gar nicht etabliert warum nehmen die nicht einfach
patreon wahrscheinlich weil patreon kein porn erlaubt oder alles da kann ich mir nicht
erklären ok leute scrollt das aber schnell in den chat durch
man kommt dann die webcam in den heizungsraum da ist doch schon eine drin
heute noch mal battlefield 3 morgen vielleicht jetzt gehe ich ins bett also chat wir sehen
uns morgen bis dann machts gut cu